two new cracks opened our spewing lava
and toxic gas on Hawaii's Big Island
where the Kilauea volcano has destroyed
at least 35 buildings Carter Evans is
outside Leilani estates in Pahoa where
more than 1700 residents have now been
evacuated Carter good morning good
morning the lava flow actually slowed a
little bit last night but those
dangerous gases are still coming from
those very large cracks in the earth the
lava could start flowing again at any
time and scientists don't know when this
eruption will end new video shows the
fiery wrath of Kilauea bearing down on
the neighborhood of Leilani estates
nothing in the lavas path was spared it
consumed telephone poles trees and homes
all destroyed is the once lush landscape
now looks more like a blackened moon
scape but yesterday a much-needed break
the eruptions slowed down and
authorities are now allowing evacuees to
briefly return to their homes to pack
their most essential items
kalenna kealoha moved here last
September with his wife and two young
daughters after fleeing California's
wild fires was nice and green everything
was green look at it all fall dying we
were with him as he packed up a house he
says he may never see again I'm gonna
raise my daughters here but it doesn't
look like it's gonna turn out to be the
scenario we hope neighbors tell me this
Fisher has been spewing lava for the
last couple of days you could see some
of it flying through the air now but at
one point it was going much farther
landing over here on the neighborhood
street where we are you can see here
it's stuck to the asphalt I'll stay here
until I can't stay anymore Michael
Clemens decided not to evacuate he says
almost all of his life savings is in his
home just a few hundred yards away from
the lava and noxious smoke you know
these things happen it's happened to
other people it happened to me now so
you know I'll do the best I can and
endure on Hawaii Governor David EJ is
urging people to
mein cautious just because we had one
calm day doesn't mean it's over
yes definitely everyone knows that it's
not over
while volcanoes are extremely dangerous
they are considered sacred here in
Hawaii a representation of Pele the
goddess of fire and according to
Hawaiian folklore to calm her down
people will often leave offerings of
cigarettes and her favorite liquor gin
JOHN CARTER thanks that's a new one I
did not know that